[ __ ] sleep so so so this is people think
i don't like sleep or i don't support
sleep or i think
you know you and it's not true and and i
would say when people oh you think
you're
you're giving people advice that's
unhealthy here's the actual advice that
i give people
from the book sleep is a necessity
humans need sleep failure to get enough
sleep has serious side effects
lack of sleep can cause negative
hormonal changes interfere with the
metabolizing glucose of glucose increase
blood pressure
and suppress the immune system less
sleep also means less human growth
hormone
in your body which means less muscle
mass and weaker bones
mentally the brain is impacted as the
ability to pay attention and concentrate
begins to diminish and problem solving
and basic reasoning becomes
less acute furthermore over an extended
period there are
psychological effects like paranoia and
even hallucinations
so that's me talking about sleep you
need to sleep
i'm not anti-sleep
isn't there a thing called a fast
sleeper yeah something about that
we'll get there we'll get there so so
check this out
but how much sleep is enough different
people need different amounts of sleep
newborns can sleep up to 17 hours a day
toddlers can sleep 12 hours a day as
people grow older
less sleep is required teens generally
need 8 to 10 hours
and by the time people are full of
adults eight hours becomes the standard
even though the actual number is between
seven and nine hours depending on the
individual
some people genetically need even less
sleep than that but those people are
rare
i'm one of those people and this isn't i
don't have the proof
well here's my proof
my oldest daughter is like me like last
night she was studying
she's went to bed at midnight i woke up
at 4 30 she's up
and then she took an exam cognitive not
impaired right she's going to get an a
you know what i'm saying so but but my
second daughter
that girl likes to sleep like she'll get
out of bed when you go drag her out of
bed right like she likes to sleep
my son kind of it's kind of normal i
would say
my wife she digs that sleep mm-hmm so
some of my kids get some of it my
youngest daughter she's sort of
a little bit i would that sleep too yeah
but but so there is so so i think there
is
some sort of genetic thing
um here's
but it's it's people also go well
it's so rare there's no chance you have
it okay cool
i'm only i can only tell you people like
people say sleep more
i i i'm not trying to sleep less i'm
more than happy to sleep
you know but it just doesn't happen
so going on here but it isn't only
genetics you can also sleep less and
fall asleep faster if you are in good
physical condition eating clean and have
a clear mind
for me the better condition i'm in and
the cleaner i eat
the more quickly i will fall asleep and
the less sleep i need do you notice this
do you notice that you need less sleep
when you're fasting um
i i don't notice but i'm not paying
attention to it okay
i like when i'm when i'm fasting i feel
like i'm on fire
yeah and i i just did a fast i just did
a 48 hour
and i feel i felt like again like i was
waking up earlier than i'd normally wake
up yeah
so while i do have short sleep genetics
on my side
equally important is that i stay healthy
and eat clean
what about when you eat junk how don't
you need to sleep more
oh yeah but actually you know what it's
real real inconsistent when you eat junk
or sorry when i eat junk
it's sometimes i'll sleep less but
be wanting to sleep more but you know
the kind like you're tired and you feel
sleepy but you can't
like go to sleep you know it's like that
there's a lot of that
that's the worst thing oh yeah i agree
you feel like you wish you would sleep
more but you can't
you kind of can't just get up yeah
exactly and feel like crap or whatever
and sort it you know
maybe catch the next wave of sleepiness
i guess
the and on the inverse when you're
talking about like when you
exercise consistent you eat clean or
whatever and it's really different where
and it's really
real clear where it feels freaking solid
during the day and then once that
bedtime ish kind of rolls around you
just feel the wave just crash
and you're like oh it's it's sleep time
so straight up it's so
good yeah it's real just when you worked
out hard you had a good day you ate
clean
you get to the end of the day you're
like boom you're out bro that's how i
was yesterday and i
and i got like an hour less sleep than i
normally did the day before
so but i got up solid boom eating good
now that we're thinking about this when
i have like those weird roller coaster
brain rides
that's usually that's usually when i'm
like something's
messed up you know whether i'm eating
crap or
or whatever yeah
bro i was the kind like i do quizzes
and story time from with the kids before
bed every night this is like what 8
o'clock 8 30.
but i was the time like it's like kind
of in the middle
of a question that i'm asking it's
you falling asleep straight up that's a
good day right there yeah i was like
okay it's about that time you know yeah
i i've i've had that where when my kids
were little and i was still in the damns
and
you know you're just getting up at 4 30
you're doing whatever you're doing at
work come home
you know and you're just getting bed to
read that story next thing you know it's
three o'clock in the morning four
o'clock in the morning what just
happened
my wife left me in there because she was
running around with three kids at the
time
you know trying to get them all squared
away she like oh you got the kid
school she probably went to a bar i
don't know what she did she
knows that girl went to sleep she used
to fall asleep with some one kid
almost every night it was crazy
so going on here and finally i choose
not to sleep in
i don't give into the pillow i don't
give in to the temptation
of warm blankets or soft pillow i
mobilize the will to get me out of bed
and get into the game
obviously i'm an advocate of waking up
early but since
sleep must be a priority to maintain
health how can we get enough sleep and
still wake up early
the answer is simple go to bed earlier
go to bed earlier now
i'm going to skip a little bit here go
forward well this
i talk about some of the benefits like
what are the benefits why do i wake up
early
and i mean first there's some simple
math but why do you wake up early the
world's is yours
when you're up before the enemy there's
no traffic the gym is empty there's no
one to distract you
or call you or send you some stupid text
about something you don't care about
so there's like all these benefits to
being
up early but then going back to the
other point
falling asleep how do you fall asleep so
this is kind of what we were just
talking about number one and there's a
whole section i'm going to read some
highlights of it number one get tired
yes get tired if you are not active
throughout the day you won't be tired
you know what's weird is recording the
podcast depending on the podcast
i'm usually super wired when we get done
recording
and then i'm tired you know it's a
mental
it's a mental work yeah fully number two
turn off the computer
turn off the smartphone stop checking
social media and stop
watching one more youtube video
sure there's some science that says that
the light from the computer
and phone screen tricks your mind into
thinking is daylight and time to get up
but on top of that the internet is
filled with professionals that create
content with the sole purpose of getting
you to click on it yes clickbait is real
and just like the bait used in fishing
it is a trick
to get you hooked so don't don't click
it you will get nothing positive at all
number three read if your mind is still
active when you reach your bedtime
that's okay
get into bed and get a book and start
reading reading is relaxing it settles
your mind and makes you smarter so do it
dude reading will reading
i think reading is a massive sleep aid
yeah
yeah every once in a while like you not
every once well most of the time
actually in my experience because i want
to be reading a boring book
unless it's for a specific purpose but
usually they're interesting books
so at first i might be like oh kind of
excited but yeah man
after and it depends on the day or
whatever but it can be like after like
10 minutes 15 minutes
i you know the kind of books i read
because i read them on the podcast all
the time i'm talking about books about
war and combat in the most
dynamic heroic situations like even
those books
if i'm reading i'll be like oh if it's
night time and i'm reading i'll i will
get tired off all sleep yeah i mean
i won't i don't fall asleep while i'm
reading i rarely do that but i'll be
like okay i'm tired yeah yeah i'm gonna
shut the book and go to bed
oh yeah then that's exactly what i'm
saying where maybe at first if it's
like super interesting or exciting or
whatever book you're like at first
you're like oh man let's
get some reading going you know about
this whatever you're reading about and
then yeah after
like i said it depends on how your state
of mind is but
as far as time goes but yeah after a
little while right you're ready you're
ready to go sleep
i just got done reading a book for the
podcast that it was
it was a book that i like was actively
couldn't sleep because i just was like
i'm going to read this more of this
because i want to know what's about to
happen
it's freaking crazy
number four most important the key to
getting to sleep early
is getting up early no it might not help
you tonight but tomorrow night it will
if you need seven full hours of sleep
and you want to get up at 4 30 a.m that
means you
need to go to bed at 9 30 pm but it is
hard to
force yourself to sleep at 9 30. so you
stay up until
11 30. you should still get up at 4 30.
yes that will only be five hours of
sleep and yes you will likely feel tired
throughout the day
which is actually good because at the
end of the day you want to be tired
now you can go to bed at 9 30 and get
yourself back on track
yeah that's that's the part that people
if you want to be tired at night at 9 30
you need to get up early you can't you
can't get up at
nine in the morning and expect to be
tired
at nine at night it won't happen yeah
and the last thing is do it every day
right and this is like you know
weekends whatever just do the same time
look if you want to give yourself an
extra half an hour i don't even
recommend that i recommend you get up at
the same time every day
yeah that um
here's a mistake i think that well when
i say some people
me i make this mistake or i have made
this mistake straight up where i'll be
like okay yeah i'm going to do that i
want to get up early you know
earlier whatever so i'll just wake up
earlier and be tired throughout the day
but what i did is i didn't look at the
big picture i was like i'll just
automatically be tired at night you know
but
what i did was i would laze through the
day skip workout
a lot of laying down on the couch you
know a lot more than normal
and then you know basically
since you're tired you kind of adjust
your activity accordingly you know in a
bad way
so you do just way less and then night
time comes you're not as tired as
you could have been if you just went
about your normal routine sure you gotta
power through it a little bit harder
for sure if you're on less sleep or
whatever but at the end when it comes
time to sleep which was your goal it's
going to
be way more like it's going to happen
way easier you know
or it's going to happen in my case it
just straight up doesn't happen i'm
freaking out late again
can't go sleep whatever yep got to be
careful so yeah do the normal routine
don't be slacking i got a little section
on here on power naps people like do you
take naps
yes i do if i'm super tired but i and i
explain the whole thing in here elevate
your feet above your heart which i
learned from one of my high school
teachers
and then i only sleep for like eight
minutes yeah
and if you're really tired eight minutes
seems like you just got a full-on
massive amount of sleep yeah remember we
were talking about the two types of
tired
there's that oh yeah yeah there's sleepy
tired and then there's like physical
fatigue
yeah and then you know what it kind of
in the whole eight minute nap thing
sometimes six minutes it's almost like
and this is all
what do you call hypothesis we'll call
we'll say that where
if like if you could just like if you
just did like a
marathon freaking podcast or you know
after you do a podcast you mentioned
where you're kind of tired you know
something that that that required
like cognitive effort for a
somewhat sustained amount of time you
you're not exhausted physically but
mentally you might have like
this sharpness that you usually have is
just dull because like you're you're
like it's almost like a superficial
conscious like
cognitive like a bit almost that's what
it almost seems like so
if i'm working on something on the
computer like admin
numbers or freaking stuff not
editing stuff like you know work for
like
three hours and then it's workout time
i'm gonna take one of those six minutes
eight minutes and it helps so
much yep for sure but the thing is like
six minutes eight minutes what can what
can possibly recover in that i don't
know
try it it's something it's real oh yeah
it's real and
it's like you ever have a dream in eight
minutes oh yeah yeah full-on dreams
you ever have those little half dreams
like okay so usually it happens
does your body move yes but it's
something very specific though where
sometimes you just like feel like oh you
just jump ran almost like
oh no it's because someone's swinging a
battle axe in my head
that makes sense but yes it's that
though it's something specific where
like
like the other day i was i was getting
one in and
my son in my little dream it lasted
literally like two seconds it's like a
two second dream almost
and my son like ran under my legs and i
like i had to jump
over them okay in my dream yeah so i
jumped and i was like that's what caused
me to jump
but it was i remember it was my son ran
under my legs that sounds a lot more
pleasant than a battle axe yeah a
barbarian with a battle axe yeah a minor
kill you're probably a lot different
than yours for sure